The, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the.
There I've done a set for you.
You can just clip those and keep them forever.
All right, thank you very much, Alison.
Hello everyone and welcome to an episode of Octothorpe which is out of time itself
and is nervously making its way to the awards podium on a date yet to be specified.
I'm John Coxon.
I'm Alison Scott
And I'm Liz Batty.
You can definitely use one of those tiny whimey bits of sound effect for this.
Dooty dooty do dooty do dooty.
I'll just copy it out of Doctor Who, the BBC won't mind, right?
Famously unlitigious about Doctor Who.
Uh, they probably won't notice.
Even though we're out of time, we're gonna we're gonna read some letters of comment.
Uh we recorded this episode on the third of May 2026, so this
Lock column does not feature any letters we received after that date.
And if the Hugo imploded or we collided with Andromeda or something, we have not reflected that in the discussion herein.
Mike Scott pointed out that a city on Mars is not the best precedence for inventing the Renaissance.
We don't have any cities on Mars, so it contains plenty of speculative content.
Fair
The best precedent is the movie Apollo thirteen, which was a finalist in Best Dramatic Presentation in nineteen ninety-six despite being a purely historical work with no speculative content at all.
Um what it has in common with inventing the Renaissance is it is a work which would otherwise fit right into the genre, because it's an adventure story of near future human spaceflight, which is a a favourite for Hugo voters, as we know.
So the question is really whether a work that scratches the same itches as other works that are definitely eligible and appeals to the same audience should be disqualified merely because it actually happened.
I think what Mike is doing here is the vibes argument.
Oh, love me f love me some vibes.
He's talking about itches, but he means vibes.
It's got genre vibes
He means vibes, but he's too he's too old to have vibes to be fair.
Wow.
Um Sorry Mike if you're listening.
We know he is, he writes in.
Yes, yes.
Um That didn't that came out worse than I was expecting
So I th I I think Mike is half right in that the word Apollo is the reason why this is not the appropriate precedent, but I think the actual appropriate precedent is that in nineteen seventy they gave a Hugo to the news coverage of Apollo eleven.
Which fair enough, pretty good
But still not really a dramatic presentation.
Oh.
I'm sure the actors on the Apollo sets were doing their very best, Liz.
It is actually interesting, you could argue that the Hugo voters were to the uh conspiracy theory years before most other people.
And to be fine, I've never heard of any of the other four nominees in nineteen seventy.
So I can't say if those would have won.
But h honestly, there was a pretty good run there.
Doctor Strangelove
A couple of episodes of Star Trek, 2001 a Space Odyssey, and then the news coverage of Apollo eleven.
And then in nineteen seventy-one they just didn't award one.
Brilliant.
That's weird.
Hmm.
Were there no good dramatic presentations in nineteen seventy?
Gideon, write in.
Cer certainly I've not heard of any of the nineteen seventy-one ones.
But then in 1972 it all got it all got good again because you've got a clockwork orange, the Andromeda Strain, and THX1138.
And that is that is a roster.
That was a banger yeah, yes.
We should mention that as Farah told us and other pe and I also observed
Ada wrote a lengthy argument um about why inventing the Renaissance is SFF related work
Um, which you can go which we will link to and you could go and read for yourself.
I do not agree with that, but there we go.
It's basically a long version of
It's the vibes.
When you define genre as vibes, you find an awful lot of these very, very loopy arguments about genre can just be distilled down to the sentence.
It's vibes.
And I think that I don't know.
I I think this is a good thing because I'm not sure we learn much from detailed uh categorization of genres.
But maybe I am wrong.
Um, Neil Wrightin.
Oh, Neil Wrightin.
Yeah, that sounds good.
We like it when Neil Wright in.
I'm now fascinated by the history of the best dramatic presentation, Hugo.
Why did they decline to award one in a year with Carrie Logan's run and The Man Who Fell to Earth?
That one is baffling because those are Ooh, those are good.
Those are I mean they might not be the best movies in the genre, but they're definitely better than not awarding an award.
Like it
Logan's Run is good.
Logan's Run holds up.
Like I know it's not regarded as a perfect movie, but I have watched it and I do not rec regret watching it.
There's a lot of bangers in breast dramatic presentation.
Anyway, onwards.
Yeah.
I think that might actually be a good discussion point.
for doing the episode is one of the things I think we might be judging on is how well when we draft a category, how well has that category reflected the genre.
And dramatic presentation has some wonky years, but generally speaking, it's done okay.
Wonder Woman Notwithstanding.
Are we actually doing this as a draft?
Yeah.
Because if so, we need some rules.
We do need some rules, we'll get to that
We're not there yet.
Tommy Coxon, who is the Hugo Award Administrator for 2026, uh wrote in uh
As part of our discussion that uh James Brantner is listed as James Brantner Tarval on the ballot.
Uh and Tammy says that almost everyone who nominated Brantner did so as Tarvall, so putting it on the ballot would be
just as his full name would probably be quite confusing to the people who nominated him.
And they have changed it to read aka Tavol to better convey the reasoning.
Yes.
I think this makes sense.
The point I was kind of driving at, which led to this lock, was I think if someone does something, if someone is a fanwriter and they're most notable for a single thing.
And it helps the voters to point out what that single thing is.
I think it should be highlighted on the ballot.
And it wasn't that I thought this was a bad idea.
I just think we should probably do it more generally.
Like I think Bitter Corella being called Bitter Corella makes a lot of sense.
Um, but like or Jan Weston, I think you could say, you know, brackets, micro SFF, because that is the thing he is nominated for.
And I take the point that it kind of start blurring fanzines and fan writers, but
If you are being nominated for your Perzine, I think it makes sense to p put the name of the Perzine in the category nomination to me.
And so I applaud this.
I would like to see it go forward, but I'd also like to see it done with other people who are being nominated because of their writing in a single venue.
Which I know will not be everyone, but for those people for whom it is true, why not highlight that for the voters?
That's my basic question.
But maybe one day I will administrate a Hugo Award and I can do all sorts of weird things.
Yeah
I am so looking forward to it though Octhorpe will be very dreary that year.
Well that's the thing, right?
That is the thing.
Can you talk about this, John?
No
Alright.
So yes, but thank you very much for writing in Tammy, that makes sense.
We also heard from Heather Rose Jones, who is a longtime listener and a first-time writer.
So she has written a series of blog posts called The Theory of Relativity, a history and analysis of the best related work Hugo category.
And that's soon to be a book, which I did not realise.
I'm excited about that.
I will read it with bells on.
Um but basically they said um th they feel there's a myth of a golden age of best related work.
um that people sometimes evaluate finalists against and that Golden Age never really existed.
And she basically points out that there's never been a time even when the category was best nonfiction book.
where critical works of SF were the dominant content.
That never happened.
Like they've always featured, but they've never been the majority.
Uh she also highlights that of the forty-four winners to date, only four
have been wins for something other than a physical book and and says that the types of content of finalists have been very stable through the history of the award.
Um and so I think this is an interesting thing, right?
Because you compare the finalists to the winners and if you're paying a lot of attention to the finalists that might not come up, but y when you look at the winners it's actually quite a lot more it has more of a voice than you might think it does.
And I thought that was interesting.
Um and it's an excuse to plug the fact that Heather has uh has written a series of blog posts which is going to be turned into a book.
So we will talk about that more when that happens.
Please let us know, Heather, because um we will plug it.
Um but yeah, thank you very much for writing in.
I thought it was interesting.
I'm trying to decide if I want to argue with that or not.
Ooh, go on Liz.
Go on.
Well, but then we get into like I haven't actually analyzed every single nomination.
Yeah, I think maybe when
I think maybe when I'm thinking of the golden age of like criticism, it's not all criticism, but I think there are years when there've been five substantial book length works and it is more recently
that we're at the point where sometimes we haven't had that.
If you think about the ones the the things we've awarded which are not books, then they are in 2020
twenty nineteen, presumably twenty twelve and twenty thirteen.
Depending on if we're counting the Encyclopedia of Science Fiction Third Edition as a book or not.
It's a website really
So I will I will have to go and read Olive Heather's analysis.
And come back with a with an opinion.
Yeah.
If does Encyclopedia of Science Fiction
Would be a book if they made it an EPUB, but because they've made it a website it's not a book.
And so I kind of I kinda lean towards that being a book hype
Hyperlinked text, I think, is a book if it's a book.
I don't think putting it in an EPUB file is the thing that transitions it to being a book, but I don't know.
Well.
This is a vibes discussion
Your vibe your vibe example here is Jeff Ryman's two five three, right?
Yeah, it's a book.
But it was also a website with hyperlinks that you can read out of order.
I think Cruzley is like
Uh do encyclopedias count as a thing you could read in order, or are they always a thing you dip in and out of and therefore it doesn't matter if they are a book or a website?
But I think the point I'm trying to make is that websites can be books and books can be websites.
Oh they're different.
Cause an EPUB file is just HTML in a zip, right?
And so if I put an EPUB file if I write a choose your own adventure book, is that a book?
Hmm.
Yeah, I guess it is a book.
Listeners, what is books?
Please write in.
But no, I I take your point.
I think it's interesting, 'cause I don't I think I would call the Encyclopedia of Science Fiction a book, but I do take your point that not everyone probably would.
Certainly it deserved to win the best related work, Hugo.
Like, that that one is not uh I don't think any of us disagree with that choice.
Good good win, well done all.
Yes, and in fact that may not be the one that uh Heather is referring to as not a book.
It may be in fact the essay that won Karen Hurley's essay in twenty fourteen.
But uh anyway
Not a book.
What we're saying is that all the non-book winners have been basically in the last like ten to fifteen years.
Where is the line between a pamphlet and a book?
Can you nail a book to the door of a church?
Oh, that is a great way of uh articulating it.
Okay
If you can nail it to the door of a church, it's not a book.
A foolproof definition that no one could reasonably argue with.
I like it when we get letters.
But yeah, thank you very much for writing in Heather.
That was really interesting
Okay, let's do a Hugo Award category draft.
So
Here's the thesis.
The Hugo Award.
There are too many categories.
Everyone agrees except for Christopher J.
Garcia.
That's true.
And we are going to No, no.
What?
That's about the right number of categories.
Oh, hello.
Maybe slightly too many?
Slightly too many.
Oh hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
A little bit of a a little bit of a debate, a little bit of a discussion.
Um but in order to But I think everyone agrees that there's something wrong with the Hugos, it's just not everyone agrees on what the something is
But we all have our little bugbear about it.
Even those who love them very much.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna fix it, listeners.
We're gonna each draft a roster of Hugo Awards, which will be the objectively correct
Hugo Award categories.
And we need to work out the rules.
We don't know who's going first and who's going second and who's going third, but we're not going to do it in traditional John Alice and Liz order because that would be unfair.
What order are we doing it in then?
We and what are we actually doing?
And I'm looking at these categories and if I pick dramatic presentation television, then where's the dramatic presentation film?
I'm glad Alison has uh done some preparation in advance
That is literally all the preparation in advance.
I think that dramatic presentation long form is also film.
But then there is an overlap and also in in big big big time overlap.
I don't think you can reasonably if someone picks best dramatic presentation long form, you're not allowed to pick best dramatic presentation movie.
No, but am I allowed to pick Best Dramatic Presentation Television?
Because some plenty of stuff on television is long form.
No, I wouldn't say plenty.
No, because why would the long form definition exist?
You're picking best dramatic presentation television.
Yeah, no, this is definitely gonna be a laugh.
Anyways, we should continue we should press on.
So my intent with the television best dramatic presentation is you would nominate a television series, which for the purposes of this draft would be defined as any television series with three or more episodes.
With the last episode broadcast in the last calendar year.
When you draft something, you basically also have to give uh an explanation of the rules if it's not totally obvious.
Yes.
So
I'm going to use random.
org.
Random.
org, we bring the random to you.
Uh and the list randomizer has told us that the order will be Alison, then me, then Liz.
Alright, so how m how many rounds are we doing?
How many Hugos is the optimal?
Six.
Eighteen!
Eighteen Hugos.
You think that's the optimal number, John?
Oh no no no no no no.
We're each doing so you'll be the Worldcon Chair in Avignon.
with your Hugo Awards of six Hugos and then I'll have my six and Liz and Alison will have her six and then we will no sense John.
It's a competition guys, it's who gets the best Hugo Awards.
That's not a draft though, is it?
Yeah?
Like sports draft.
Yeah, but the idea of sports draft is you Not every team shares all the players.
Yeah, but you pick one and then I can't pick that person in a sports draft.
Are you saying that Alison gets to pick six and I can't pick any of those?
If I pick best novel, you're shit out of luck, Liz.
But are you picking six at once or one at once?
One at once, we're gonna go round.
So it's gonna be Alice and John Liz, Alice and John Liz, Alice and John Liz.
Right, fine, fine, fine.
Okay.
That kinda makes sense.
So we're gonna end up with a set of six Hugos, and I get to go first.
No six sounds fine.
And I'm allowed to invent my own if I want, right?
Yes.
This is just a
This is just a kind of jogging thing.
We have a suggested list which I believe John has compiled from all the Hugos that have ever existed.
And some more things we thought might be fun.
And some others.
Yeah.
But really I should have saved my best ideas.
Mmm.
Right, so I'm going first.
Yes.
Do I get to define my category as well?
If it's an existing category, it's the existing rules unless you say otherwise.
And you can't take the piss, like you can't pick best science fictional thing and define it as including everything.
I am going to pick as my first pick, are we ready to go then?
Yeah.
Best novel
Fuck.
Which I am going to define as a science fiction work of 80,000 words or more.
That gives you some scope.
Whoa, hang on a minute.
Why eighty thousand words or more?
It feels like about the right amount.
Okay.
When did a Lovell between forty and eighty thousand words lost win the Hugo?
Might go for 60,000.
Actually, let's go for 60,000.
That seems good.
So you've got some long novellas in your novellas.
Okay, so we're basically we're we're extending the novella category to up to sixty thousand
Well, I don't know, do what you want.
But I'm basically going I'll have novel and in order to not take uh the all the shine I'll say I am not having short novels.
The short novels can go somewhere else
Alright, so why best novel, Alison?
Why best novel?
Because I think this is the one that most people who are outside our tiny little bubble care about.
more than any of the others.
And I think it's also the one that most people who are inside I tied little problem care about more than the others.
And I came first on random.
org, so that's what I'm having.
Because I want my in my Hugo Awards in in the bath, I want um I want to have the most prestigious Hugos and so that's what I'm doing.
Also, it means that all the very famous orthotypes will come to my will come to my tiny convention where I award my
Hughes.
Liz, would you have gone for best novel first?
Yeah, I probably would have gone for best novel just because well well partly because I know Ali if I hadn't then Alison would have gone for it, and so if I was first I would have gone for it to annoy Alison
Which is obviously a very rational way of picking my set of Hugo categories.
A hundred percent, yeah.
But you know, y I I agree, like that that's the one people care about.
That's the one people actually put on the front of things.
That's the one that actually arguably
sells books?
I mean if you look at the one that people actually vote for and nominate for, it's best novel.
I don't think
that many extra novellas are sold because it says best Hugo on the cover.
And people also like to vote in dramatic presentation, but I don't think that really matters at all.
to the people who the number of people overall who watch and listen to these things.
I mean I think we all know the thing that sells novellas is having the words Tor.
com written on the spine.
So, who's Snippy today then?
I f I didn't think that was too snippy.
I thought that was funny.
Maybe it wasn't.
It's quite funny.
I'm gonna go next.
Um and I don't know.
I'm I'm following my heart here because I think there's an argument that this is the wrong choice, but I am gonna pick best game or interactive work.
Boo!
Partly because I didn't think it would get around to me in the next go, as is evidenced by Alison saying boo quite loudly.
Also because I love games, but also because I think this category has consistently been
finalists of a very high caliber and has rewarded the electorate with interesting choices.
And I think because it is in its infancy, there is a potential that it could become
a relevant award to the gaming community.
Certainly the companies that get nominated seem to be enthusiastic about it if the voter packet is anything to go by.
Open brackets, except Nintendo Boo.
Close brackets.
Except Nintendo, yes.
Nintendo Nintendo do their own thing.
They they march to their own drum.
But yes, so I'm picking best game or interactive work, which I'm gonna guess is not a surprise to either of you.
Are you going to redefine the category or use the one as exists now?
I am tempted to redefine it to be explicitly video games, but then the problem is someone else might snipe board games.
Maybe they would, maybe they wouldn't.
Who can say, Tom?
No, I'm not redefining it, Liz.
I'm just gonna do a concerted public information campaign about board games for my Hugo.
I feel I have been uh You have been randomly stiffed.
I feel that in order to not have a set of
shall we say, the least commercial Hugo Awards in history.
Can I just check?
Should we be doing a sh snake draft?
Oh.
We could do a snake draft.
Oh, so I get two.
Mmm.
Yeah, alright, let's do a snake draft.
For those who don't know, that means it will go John, it'll go Alison John, Liz Liz, John, Allison, Allison, John, Liz, Liz, etc.
Mm-hmm.
If you any listener who suspects that we are making things up as we go along, yes, you are quite right.
Well I mean I'm leaving all of the rules discussion in.
So they won't suspect they'll have the evidence.
Alright, I'm having for my first Hugo dramatic presentation.
Film.
Oh.
And I'm gonna redefine it as film.
And film will be defined in the same way as like the lengthwise it has to be whatever the current one is, which I think is like 70 minutes or over
Mm-hmm.
And it has to have had a oh I was gonna define it as theatrical release, but that like rules out Netflix.
Basically
I'm gonna say it's the best film and I'm gonna define film in a sensible way that everyone will know when they look at it
Good luck with that singers.
Nobody's been able to do it for the Oscars.
But in fact all of the all the good ones do actually get a theatrical release.
They just kinda put it in two theatres on a Thursday.
Yeah, I mean no one's gonna theatrically release stuff just so it gets a Hugo Award apart from three people who wrote a short film and think that would be neat.
I'm gonna say it has to not be part of a
T V series I was gonna say not part of a longer work, but then I've ruled out like
Star Wars.
Yes, you need I think I think there is a coherent way of doing this.
I don't know what that coherent way is.
The coherent way of doing this might be that if
I was picking, you know, as many as I wanted, then there would probably be a T V series award and it would be things that don't fit in T V series.
But I'm expecting that will not be there unless I pick it next
So we're gonna go with film and not go for too much definitional wrangling.
It has to not be a TV series, it's a film.
Alright.
And I'm going for this in the hope that one day
Someone famous would turn up to my Hugo Award.
Good shout.
I think I was expecting those three to be the first three that went.
I wasn't necessarily expecting Allison to pick Norvel.
I thought she might pick game.
Thought about it.
If I had gone first, I think I would have picked game.
Yeah, well that would have been good then because we could have gone John Allison Liz, I'd have got novel, everyone would have been happy.
In terms of film, I think what you want is vibes.
Cause I think I know what a film is, and I think we all know what a film looks like, right?
But I think as soon as you start saying, Oh, I don't know, I don't want it to be part of a series then you start to realise that actually lots of films are parts of series and that doesn't matter.
So it it is complicated.
You could do the definition so that like I don't think anyone's arguing that all nine Star Wars films should be nominated as a single work in this category.
So I think you could you you could do something around the the only problem I foresee is you might end up in a situation where technically speaking long episodes of TV shows are eligible and that's when it gets complicated, I think.
What did you guys expect the first three to go to be?
Was it these three?
Yeah, one hundred percent.
'Cause I think you're gonna have to have a marquee Hugo in your Hugos, aren't you?
I didn't really think about it, but it is totally unsurprising to me that that novel went first because that's the big one.
And then in hindsight it's very unsurprising that John picked games because John loves games
And then I'm like, well I'm having a good one then aren't I?
So yeah.
And now you're getting another good one.
Come on.
What's your second pick?
Hmm.
So now I get to another good one.
Right, what do I want second?
Mmm
Video essay?
I mean I did put that in.
Editor long form.
I'm gonna have best publisher.
Absolute left field choice for second pick.
Mm-hmm.
Oh wow, and why?
What an absolutely bananas thing to say.
It has been honest things to say, especially given how critical I have been of the Locust Award Best Tour Award for Best Tour.
And there is a risk that this would turn into the Tour Award.
Could be Tour.
com.
Not the same publisher, yeah.
Well it's ReactorNow, right?
Or is Taur are the novellas still Tor.
com and the magazine is ReactorNow?
Think so, yes.
Okay
But anyway, my argument for this is I was thinking that there are some publishers who I think are doing really interesting things
by having a really interesting slate of works and we don't currently reward that.
I don't really like best editor long form because I feel I can't judge editor apart from
on which books they choose to buy and publish, because I don't know how they are editing them, but I do think you can judge editors on the books they commission, purchase, decide to publish, whatever.
And so therefore I am picking best publisher because you'd be able to reward things like Neon Hemlock, who I think are publishing some of the most interesting
novellas out there.
I was looking at Solaris books.
Solaris books are like putting up like a list of all the books we are putting on sale for Earth today and I thought, ooh, that is a really interesting set of books.
Uh you could reward like Haikosoru
who are doing all those translated Japanese books for a while and that was their whole line.
You know, you can reward publishers who are doing interesting things
The downside here is that you may not reward the publishers who are doing interesting things.
You may reward the ones who publish the most books that get on the Hugo shortlist or similar.
So in the same way there's an argument that, you know, you could instead of best editor just give an uh a Hugo to the editor who edits the best novel of the year, or similar.
you could give one to the publisher instead.
But I think it's a niche that I would like to see rewarded.
I think there is an opportunity here to give it to some of the small publishers that don't otherwise get much love
And I think it would make for a very interesting discussion of like, okay, whose set of books this year were the most interesting?
There you go.
I like it.
Something you said about um editor made me wonder.
Alison, with your best novel, who gets the award?
Is it just the author?
Is it the author and translator if there is one, or is it the author and editor?
I love the idea of giving a Hugo to the author and a Hugo to the editor.
That sounds amazing.
But obviously there are cases where people just write it in their basement and and uh publish it.
Yeah, that's true.
Liz's best publisher.
I thought you were gonna say Neon Hemlock um as your example, 'cause I know you are a big fan of them.
Mm-hmm.
Um, but yeah, I think this is a cool idea.
I do I do worry it will be dominated by a big publisher
Maybe there's ways around that.
We should have a draft of Hugo by laws next time we do this.
Do you do you do you want people to stop listening, John?
We know our listeners and they love it.
They they the the nerdier we get the more they like it, right?
I do not have
a Hugo for best novel in my set of Hugos, right?
Yeah.
So there is a risk that Best Publisher comes by proxy.
Best novel.
But on the other hand, in my Hugos maybe no one is voting
'Cause I don't have any good awards.
So yeah.
Right.
Alright.
John gets one?
I do get one.
I am going for Best Dramatic Presentation Television.
So Jonas Snipe Me Again.
Solid.
If I was gonna argue obviously novel and
Actually in the twenty-first century, movies have been doing a lot of great SF and looking through the best dramatic presentation long form, I think my perception that movies
do not do good SF is flatly wrong because there's a lot of good movies on that list and I'm like, oh actually there's some cool stuff happening here.
But I think
Especially in the modern era, television is where a lot of good SF is happening.
How how are you defining this then?
This is television series.
So be you nominate your favorite series.
Um if you have a favorite episode but the series overall was a bit ropey, I mean you can nominate the series, that's fine, but like it's specifically for
series not for individual episodes.
I think my main problem with short form is that realistically I don't think about television series in terms of
how good each episode is, I think about the the whole that they create.
And I don't think that was always true, but certainly in the last ten or fifteen years I think it's much more true for how I evaluate television
And so like, you know, often I'm like, well I want to nominate this series and I'm like, uh well which which episode will other people nominate and will it be that one or will it be this one?
Um and I just like do away with that.
Just, you know, nominate series.
So when I was young, almost all television was essentially standalone.
There might be some ARC stuff.
probably not even very much ARC stuff, but basically you have a set of you have a cast and then stuff is resolved within the episode and then an award for best television episode makes some sense.
The vast majority of mon and I never liked any of that in science fiction 'cause I thought it was pretty bad way of doing SF.
Um there's an honourable exceptions, but they're quite
few whereas what we've got now which is the series the the science fiction series is generating lots and lots of great stuff so uh yeah no that's a great one to have and it is in fact the one I would have picked next but there we go.
So
Yeah, well done John.
That's two out of two sniping my next category so far, so we'll see if you can keep that up.
Sorry, Alison.
Okay, so I get two now.
You do.
So I feel my Hugos are not going to attract the clientele I want unless I have something for stuff we watch rather than stuff we read.
So I am gonna take best short form, which I don't think is there yet.
So this is standalone things that are seventy minutes long or less and aren't episodes of a larger television series, clearly, 'cause, you know, unless it's a series like
I guess Black Mirror or something like that where it's telling individual stories.
I think you could have that you could I think they're still eligible in this, but otherwise it's all your short films, short plays
Acceptance species, I suppose, please don't.
Um stuff like that.
News broadcasts.
Yeah, and I think nowadays we understand that news broadcasts are dramatic presentations in ways we might not have done in nineteen seventeen.
Yep.
So that's my that's my number six.
So that's my two, my second one.
Okay.
Interesting.
And then I think I get another one.
You do.
Hoo hoo.
Yeah, and I think my next one.
I'm gonna call it Best Slipstream, and it's the best thing that feels like it ought to be genre but isn't
Yeah, okay, cool, cool, cool.
And then this one you could put.
Um the Artemis Project.
Um you can put
the inventing the Renaissance.
Yeah.
You can put um really interesting video games that don't have any genre content.
You can put all that stuff
All that stuff that science fiction fans like but isn't actually SF.
I think that'll go well.
Or fantasy.
Or horror.
Yeah.
Not Shamra.
If it's actually SF, does that mean that the administrator is allowed to disqualify on the basis that it's SF?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, this has to not be genre.
Though no, th obviously the the administrator will be swung by the will of the n nominators because otherwise that would be wrong.
So and also I'm the administrator so basically everything's getting in here.
Oh God.
Well, well, well, well, well.
It's a good thing Alison is consistent from episode to episode on what she feels the administrator should do.
Indeed.
It's got to have some consistency.
I no, I I corrected.
I I I I didn't admittedly say no and then I I caught caught myself.
Yeah, we're administrating these, right?
Administering.
No one else is gonna do it, so I don't believe I said administrative, ignore that.
No, that seems that seems good to me.
I think having a best slipstream uh is a lovely way of doing it and the fact that it is pleasingly
ill-defined I think only reinforces the works that will be nominated.
So this is just a win all round.
Yeah.
Liz, did you have Best Slipstream on your list of of ones to pick?
I did not have best slipstream on my list of ones to pick.
Um and I don't think actually this is slipstream in the way I would think of slipstream, which is it has that kind of uncanny feeling to it.
I would say this is best science fictional vibes.
I should have called it best vibes.
I would have called it best vibes if I had thought of that.
But the the business meeting can decide to rename it later if they want to.
That is fair, that is fair.
Do you want best vibes, Alison, or Best Lipstream?
Which one which one you sticking with?
Yeah, no, I'm gonna go for Best Vibes.
Thank you for that.
I should have thought of Best Vibes, that's a much better name for this category.
Which means best slipstream is available though if you want John.
That's true, that is true.
Um, alright, no, I'm not going slipstream.
Oh no, this is where it gets tricky
Because the I think the obvious ones of Garden.
I'm going to go for best novella.
Alright, so here's my thesis.
All novels are too long.
They'd all be better if they were 60,000 words or less.
So let's just be the change we want to see in the world and only reward works where they've had a damn good editing.
And so how many Hugos are you awarding, John?
Uh I will also award to the author and editor and translator if there is one.
This is good because it means that in the first year of my Hugos, I believe there will be at least one volume of on the calculation of volume which will be eligible.
So I will be enthusiastically boosting that uh in this category and hopefully it can break the Tor.
com deadlock.
I'll need Rosanna Pendlebury on side to write lots of good criticism about which things people should nominate in my new novella category.
Um so Rosanna get your typing fingers ready.
Do your stretches?
I mean, I must unfortunately point out, John, that Rosanna being enthusiastic about novellas on the internet
has thus far made fuck all difference to the nominees.
So good luck.
Oh wow.
I mean savage.
Not untrue, but savage
It's possible John has just nicked my category and I'm feeling salty, but still.
Oh I'm sorry, Liz.
Well, no, because otherwise I would have run the risk of having two besttour.
coms, so I probably
No, that is true.
Lizthetor.
com Hugoes.
Uh yes.
Alright.
Over to you, Liz.
What what are you gonna pick?
Oh when I do I get to pick two again.
Yes, Snake Draft.
Brief pause while I remember what I already picked.
I'm gonna have best series.
Fuck off.
I thought I was safe.
No.
Motherfucker
And I'm slightly surprised even in myself.
This might need a little bit of editing for language.
I think John meant, Oh dearie me.
No, I don't think he did.
I'm putting in the show notes I said it and I meant it.
So I have complained about Best Series quite a lot in the past because I think it's too much reading.
Yeah, that's why I thought you weren't gonna pick it, Liz.
But I think it has been picking up some good stuff recently.
I don't know exactly where I would draw the line, but I would make it a little bit more flexible.
For instance, you know how we discussed that there are now like six Nivo novellas and it's still not
quite 240,000 words.
I think I would probably push that down to about at least 200,000 words and three volumes, something like that.
So we'd make it a little bit lower.
But I think there's some exciting stuff being done in Best Series.
And I'm not just saying that because I'll be nominating Dungeon Crawler Carl next year.
I think the the various tour novella series are quite interesting.
Plus Adrian Trykowski keeps writing immensely good series.
Mm-hmm
And so I think that form fills quite a good niche in my Hugo Awards to award people who are doing really, really long form content.
And also if I've only got six, then I don't mind quite so much that you're gonna have to do a lot of reading
Besides, maybe my Hugo Awards are jured or something.
Who knows?
I think I would have picked best series.
I think the arguments you've just made are the arguments I typically make.
I think
In general, the series that have won this series are good science fiction series, and I think the hallmark of a good s Hugo Award is a Hugo Award that consistently awards good things in its category.
So I guess I guess one thing I want to ask Alison and you is do you think there is mileage in making things ineligible for novel if they are
up for series.
I don't award novels.
Yeah.
Don't well obviously not.
Because you're you're cross-competing.
We have competing categories here, so
Oh, are we running all of our different sets of Hugo's simultaneously and seeing who gets the most votes?
Yeah, obviously, yeah, yeah.
Well then we've lost John.
Have you lost me?
No no no no.
As in we have lost because Alison has best number.
Well you've got Best Film, which is I think um I think you'll find that there's nearly as many nominations in Best Dramatic Cup Presentation Long Form and I realise I'm speaking to the master here and it's
In fact, Liz has all the facts at her fingertips.
I can't remember.
I think that what we do is we bring this all to the LA business meeting.
We're like, we want to do this for a year just to see how our thought experiment pans out and everyone will be like, yeah, let's do it.
That would be way more fun than the actual Hugo's.
Have we had Liz's second one or are we back because we're halfway through now?
No no no no no I'm uh I'm now having to I'm deciding between do I pick something because I think it might be taken before it gets back to me, do I pick something I genuinely think should be a Hugo?
That's the tension of the draft, Liz.
Yeah, it's an interesting tension.
Especially when your co-host picks series.
Gurr.
So there was a YouTuber I watch who for a while was banned from swearing.
because of the way the YouTube algorithm worked.
And so he recorded himself saying, YouTube and we'll put that over all the swears.
So we need something like that we can put over all of John's swears.
So we can get over quite how irritated he is
Buy this.
Yep, no fat, fat.
He's probably not as irritated as I am about best game.
You went first.
I did.
You went first and you could have picked it and you went for crash commerciality.
over your true love?
I did, I did, I did, it's fair.
Over the the the thing of my heart, yes indeed.
Yeah.
Yeah, we all because we all associate the best novel category with crass commerciality.
As opposed to the video game industry, which is famously a tiny cottage industry where everyone's there just for the love.
Alright, I'm having best novelette.
Wow.
Short stories, a lot of them are too short, not as good.
Novelette, just the right length.
Good stuff.
Hmm.
Yeah, I think that's fair.
I think novelettes are good.
I mean I possibly would have kind of done a slightly
If I if I didn't think it would be rude to do this, then I would probably say instead of novelette you could have basically short fiction which we defined as being shorter than either Allison's novel or John's novella.
I I think you could do that and then we'll get one fiction category each.
I think I'm happy for you to do that if you want to.
I'm I'm cool with that.
I think that's good
Okay, if you're if you're both not very sad because I've stolen short story, then yeah we'll have Oh no, I mean don't get me wrong, I'm Urious.
I'm furious because I was the thing I was deciding between in mine was novella series or short story
And now I find out that I definitely shouldn't have picked Novella.
So like that was poor strategy on John's part, but I mean Liz, you've played the game.
Mmm it was 'cause I probably wouldn't have picked novella.
In which case, if I'm allowed to, then I would really find novellette as uh short fiction, just best short fiction
So I think it's interesting I want to pick up something that I think is interesting, which is if you hadn't if you'd had to pick between novelette and short story, you would have gone novelette.
Yeah.
So it's interesting that like we're halfway through and no one had gone for short story, which is the lifeblood of the genre.
It's so not
I also didn't think you guys would pick it.
There's some strategy here.
I would probably have picked it ne I would have picked it before it got back to you, Liz.
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean maybe it's just recent ones that I have enjoyed, but I have I think enjoyed some of the novelettes.
more looking at the recent the recent lists.
It's tricky, right?
Because I think short fiction can be really good, but I also think it can be very ins insubstantial.
And I think novelettes that get nominated tend to be
of a certain quality, which means you don't get bloated short stories, you get short fiction that is using the length to do interesting stuff
Mm.
I mean I th I think you're right.
I think it's just that I think writing a really cracking, very short story is difficult.
And I think my memory is tainted by some past winners that were
just overly sentimental and not so good.
However, having said that, I did really like the winner in uh
Twenty twenty three Rabbit Test, I really like the one in twenty twenty two, Where Oak and Hearts Together by Sarah Pinska.
That one was great.
There have been some cracking things in there, but there's also good ones in Novelette.
Mm mm-mm.
Yeah no true.
I think Rabbit Test would have worked better as a novelette because I think she might have been able to do the ending better.
I think Rabbit Test would've been s slightly better at longer length and I think where Open Hearts to Gather was exactly perfect at the length it was.
So that's a vote for short story.
Liz, are you going to award the award just to the author or will the editor get a rocket as well?
The author gets a rocket.
No editor.
No.
If you publish lots of great short stories, then you can have one for being in best publisher.
There you go.
Oh hello.
Interesting, interesting.
I think this is showing a distinction between the shorter form and the longer form because although I'm sure there is tons of editing goes on in short form, um, how much of it is the kind of really nuts and bolts making the novel a better thing that you get in novel and novella
Oh interesting.
Hard to say.
There.
Right, well there we go.
I hope I've ruined your turn, John.
Thanks, Liz.
This is why everyone loves playing board games with me.
Yep.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
So I've got three left to pick
I'm gonna make a list of what I think might wanna be on that.
You know, sometimes when you play like kind of really long board games and people get to the end and it's like, I must now plan the exact optimal move.
That is John.
It's quite funny.
I I saw a a great description of of this yesterday, which is you should rate everyone on a one to ten scale where is where one is.
I play every turn on vibes and ten is let's open a spreadsheet and really math it out properly.
I I am a sliding scale.
Very much vibes at the beginning.
Very much optimization towards the end.
Yeah.
So so I I go for vibes, vibes, vibes, and then sometimes there'll be a crunch turn where I'm slightly less vibey but still vibes.
I don't win a lot of board games, but I have a lot of fun doing it.
Uh I'm on the vibesy side.
But I can understand that given the stakes in this one are so high, I can understand why John is about this money.
And the great thing is that John's AP has given me time to map out my next three picks.
Oh god.
Okay, so I think I am going to pick
I'm gonna pick best related work.
Ooooooooh.
Oooooooh I've been Owen and R in.
We've got a couple of things in our big list of categories, listeners.
We've got best non-fiction book and we've got best critical work.
But actually, I think best related work I am persuaded by Heather's argument earlier in the episode that the voice of best related work is remarkably consistent.
And sometimes it misfires, but I think every category occasionally misfires and related work is a good category.
I am going to redefine it.
So that, firstly, no conventions are eligible.
And secondly, nothing that happens at a Worldcon is eligible.
So that's acceptance speeches and poems read at Hugo ceremonies and etc.
are explicitly ineligible.
And launches of drama and launches of fabulous new musical shows and If the musical show happens after the Worldcon as well, that's fine, I think.
Well what about the po the poem probably happened after the Worldcon as well?
Well, it it hasn't been published anywhere else.
It it got published in the Worldcon newsletter.
Mm, okay.
But like it's never been reprinted as far as I can tell.
But m but mostly this is to avoid the some of the self-referentiality that I think is is not my cup of tea.
So you're basically best related work that does not eat its own tail.
Yes.
Yeah.
Redefined to avoid aroberuses.
And again it's so we could still eliminate some parts of your category by defining categories because it's 'cause best related work is stuff that doesn't fit in other categories, right?
And we still have some other categories to go.
Actually that's a that's a great point.
So it's anything that isn't a game, a television series, or a novel or a novella.
I've actually I've actually played an absolute blinder here by picking the everything else category, uh which is now off the board.
I hadn't thought of that.
But no, I like I say, I was basically I want to capture all of the phenomenal Yeah.
Hmm.
like critical thought and analysis in the genre and all of the kind of historical work in the genre and and all of that kind of thing and like
The City on Mars was one of my favourite books the year I read it.
Um so like I I want all of those to be present and so I'm picking best related work.
I presume that now kind of takes best critical work off the board
No, I'm gonna say it should be the other way around and that best fa best related work always has to only be all the things that are not in any other category.
Hmm.
Well if that's true I might I might go for best critical work because if if that means kind of
everything else, then basically John's Hugo is now a moving target for everything else that we pick.
I think I'm happy to say that I get the idea of John's in spirit, which is to take the current Yes
set of things we encompass in it and just do some exception uh some exclusions to what we currently include and so I'm happy to do it on that basis and I will not.
Nick all critical works.
So I think my best related work is the sorts of things that are currently done.
So I think it does take non-fiction book and critical work off the board, but I think it doesn't take like professional magazine off the board.
I think you could still have that.
It doesn't take best translated work off the board.
I don't think it takes best video essay off the board because they don't tend to be nominated in BRW.
Had one a couple of years ago.
Did we both suck our teeth in sharply at that point?
Cause they definitely do.
It can take video essay off the board.
Does it take best website out?
No, you see this is getting very complicated.
I think video essay and website are not sufficiently often represented in BRW that they should be eliminated by me picking it.
Okay, I think that's a fair, you know, spirit of the award.
Yes.
So it's back to me and I get two?
And I'm going to pick two people.
Ooh.
I am going to pick best new writer.
Oh hello.
Roughly roughly with the astounding current eligibility because I don't really understand it
quite by the love, but basically I want somebody I might make it three years rather than two.
I want somebody at the beginning of their career, please.
Would you include the current eligibility, which is that if you have previously published works outside the genre, you can still be nominated for The Astounding?
Yeah, I think that's fine.
I think it's completely fine for Shakespeare to come up with his science fiction play.
You know, he's done sixteen plays and they've all been great, but now we have the tempest.
And suddenly CESF
Yeah, I think I I I th I confess I think that is fair.
So best best news genre writer.
Yeah.
Though if you've previously won Best Vibes, you're ineligible for this category.
You can't previously have won a Hugo
Oh, you can't premises have won a Hugo.
Yeah, I don't think I don't think best new writer can have have won a Hugu won won a Hugo before, because they're not new enough if they have.
Ooh, so if I so in your in your category, if I become a novelist now, I'm ineligible because I've won for Octothorpe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oof, okay.
Yeah.
People for the start of career people
Oh no, maybe I don't know, complicated, isn't it?
Are we gonna have any fan Hugos?
Are we going to have any fan Hugos listeners?
It's a great question.
It depends what Alison picks next, I suspect, from the grin on her face
I mean I w I would say your your risk here is something like, say, Ted Chiang comes along, writes an amazing short story, and we give it a Hugo
But he doesn't get nominated in Best New Writer and then he keeps writing amazing short stories and you can't nominate him.
Yeah, fine.
What?
But you can still I understand that, but fair enough.
'Cause he he won, you know, and and also there's, you know, a rival which is just best Ted Chiang.
Is that gonna be one of your categories, best Ted Chang?
No, but you know I'm tempted.
More people should make movies out of Ted Chang's short stories.
I would agree with that.
In fact, do that instead of making movies out of Andy Weir novels there.
I'm your consultant for the Hollywood industry.
No, I would strongly disagree because Andywear novels are not good books, but make good films.
Whereas I suspect that arrival might have been a one off.
And imagine if someone tried to make a te an a movie from another Ted Chang story and it was abysmal, we'd all be so sad.
That's fair, fair.
Oh, so you think it's better to make movies out of bad novels so we're not so disappointed?
Yeah, and also because then I can say, well, the novel was bad but at least this, you know, redeems it.
I'm gonna say something controversial here and the thing I'm gonna say is I don't think there's a correlation between quality of adaptation and quality of original work.
I was thinking in the specific case of Andy Weir has written two novels I don't like that I've made into two films I do.
Oh, I didn't like Project Hail Mary.
I am picking a second thing, and the second thing is number one fan face.
I think number one fan face is the wrong title, so it's just going to be best fan, and this is the award for the person who's done the best fan things
in the last year.
So it's a bit like the Big Heart, except it's not in the gift of committee.
It is the best fan.
And there are two peop groups of people who can't win it, and that is number one the people who've won it before.
And number two, the professionals.
Um, and here I'm gonna be pretty clear, if you've ever made any money for doing anything in genre where you've been paid tough, you're not winning best fan.
Gosh.
Fair enough.
Uh Alison, have you ever exhibited in an art show?
Uh yeah, no.
I mean good question.
So I mean, argue with me.
The art show is very often the The art show is the biggest problem with this sort of thing.
Okay, so we might have to have a tiny little limit to that.
It's a limit around
Um how how much Alison makes?
A thousand?
Ten thousand?
Not very much.
I I just basically
Authors authors who are also fans and big end name editors who are also fans and so on have a lot of presence.
Whereas I do want to be actually giving this award for people who like, oh tirelessly
Yeah, flying a hundred and ninety-two Romanian fans to the Easter con or whatever, you know.
People do fan things.
So this is actually interesting 'cause I had thought about this.
So this is this is kind of the Hugo equivalent of the dock queer
Yeah, no yeah, it is.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
Yeah, so it's a popularly voted best fan for the person who does the best fan things.
Okay.
No, yeah, I think that makes sense.
And it is a bit like the Dot Weir, but no sort of there's nothing on it about, oh please be a self effaced the self eff it's just the best fan.
So, you know, we don't have to think is that somebody who who everyone
Who puts it out?
But I I love the dot weir thing where the best weirs uh the best winners are the ones where everyone goes, haven't they run it already?
Yes.
It's over to me.
Unless Liz has anything on number one fan face slash best fan.
No, but we might have to have a debate and a ruling about my final category.
So let's move on.
Ooh, okay.
Alright
Mine's fancast, answering Alison's question about whether or not there would be a fan category.
Yes, I'm gonna do fancast.
Thinking about this prior to the podcast, in terms of the amount of time in my life I spend
engaging with types of media, my top two are probably games and podcasts
I listen to podcasts more than I read books.
That is a true statement about me.
Is it true for the last twelve months?
It's true on a sufficiently long timescale, but it might be true that the Clark Award has biased it slightly.
Yeah, I should think.
I'd like to think so.
But yeah, so I'm picking best fancast.
I wouldn't want our good chums at Hugo Girl to be ineligible for a Hugo in our brave new world.
And uh obviously I uh along with Alison Eliz have won this Hugo Award, so it also has a sort of place in my heart for that reason.
Um but I'm also the reason I And on your mantelpiece.
Yes.
But the reason that like I wanted to do a fancast in the first place is because podcasts are mm an important form for me.
And so yeah, I want Fancast in my thing and I would have picked it earlier, but I didn't think I'd be sniped, and thank god I was right.
Mm-hmm
What does it say that you were not sniped?
I think it says that in general the fan categories were less likely to be sniped than other categories.
Hmm.
Right, I'm gonna need a ruling here.
Oh hello.
Because I was gonna pick one that I have called, and I think I got this off someone else on the internet, the Community Benefit Award.
Ohello, ello ello ello.
Is this is the ruling is it too similar to fan?
Yes.
I think it might be.
Yeah
Liz, is this your first is this the first one that sniped you after novel?
No, I mean I probably would also have had I would have also had game and I would have also had critical work, right?
So
I'm just adaptable.
You are adaptable.
It's one of the things I say about you.
So my but my pitch here would be this is for
Things of fanish benefit that do not fit into other categories.
So this is the category in which you would put the Big Hugo spreadsheet
This is the category in which you would put AO3.
This is the category in which you might put Conor Bust.
Oh
Andrew January.
No, because it has to be a thing.
O or rather, the member p the Eastercon members portal.
The Eastercon member portal, or rather the Convention member portal, maybe.
But not Andrew, because
Andrew is a person and not a piece of software.
Yeah, yeah.
Because I've had Andrew for best fan.
Yeah.
So best community benefit I like.
Yeah, I know I like that.
And you can give it directly to the project.
Yeah.
And you could give it you could for example vote it for the Octothorpe Hugo draft, which changed the whole way that we thought about Hugos.
Maybe, but that would be even fan cast.
I really hope people are enjoying this.
I hope it's not just us.
I mean this is quite fun to do.
Yeah, I'm I'm I'm having fun listeners.
Um readers write it.
And it's only a bonus episode.
I mean if you weren't having this, what you'd have is us not doing an episode.
I'd be doing rankings of Viennese Ormond Croissons listeners.
Yeah, we've done that one, haven't we?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was saying we've we've already had we can't have more than one episode solely devoted to almond croissants, and we've had it.
I mean we can, but should we?
Readers write in.
Oh shoot, I've just thought of my sixth category
Oh I've also just worked out.
Can we have an extra round for r for really stupid categories?
Really silly ones, right.
We'll do a seventh completely stupid one, yes.
Okay.
Alright, fine, fine, fine, fine
But no, I like I like this category, Liz.
I think this is kind of I can understand why you were worried it might overlap with fan.
It also overlaps a little bit with my related work, but I'm happy for you.
No, this is great.
Yeah, but I'm taking all the stuff you don't want in related work, I think I would say.
It's tricky 'cause if Conob I didn't mind AO three gang related work.
I thought that was quite a coherent uh understood I d I was not as angry about it as many other people.
Oh, I didn't like that very much.
That's why I'm giving its own That's fair.
Didn't like it, therefore I'm giving it a completely separate category.
No, but I think there obviously people want to reward a set of stuff that don't currently fit into nice organized categories.
These are some of them.
I think conventions could also go here.
Or maybe even something you think is particularly good, like a particular a cons particularly great online offering, maybe?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yep, yep.
The only thing I would say is I don't think it should be worldcom related, or not something which primarily benefits the worldcom.
Oh hang on, but doesn't that render what does that do to the Hugo spreadsheet of Doom, Liz?
They'll do like the Hugo spreadsheet of Doom.
What I'm trying to do is avoid this becoming a thing where we just nominate like something that the Hugo's did uh that the Worldcon did every year
Mmm.
Maybe I have to think about that more if this was real.
I think you could explicitly disqualify world cons themselves.
Because you don't want it just to be awarded to last year's World Con every time.
Or ever, in fact.
I think that's what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to avoid this becoming
Oh, we'll give it to the piece of software we wrote for Worldcon.
Maybe you can't do that unless it's also heavily used by other conventions or something.
or you know, you don't give it to the Worldcon Theatre program track, something like that, right?
Mm-hmm.
I see what you mean.
You can o you can also see why we spend so much time at business meetings debating this stuff, because as soon as you start actually coming up with novel things, you then start to put novel edge cases into them.
and spend half your time arguing about those novel edge cases.
Yeah.
And to me this sort of reward, something around we I mean we got fan writer and fanzine and fan cast in the regular Hugos, but I think we don't have something that kind of
rewards what Alison is also getting at with fanface, uh which is things people do that we want to reward because they make our fanish lives better
I wanna be clear though, the fa the best fan can go to a fanwriter whose insightful essays have been the talk of fandom for the last year.
You know, it doesn't
It it doesn't i or or an or a fan artist who's um given up their time and energy to produce art materials for sixty-seven conventions, you know, that's great, right?
It doesn't it's not just so it's not just doing what the doc weir does, it's a bit i it's a bit more extended than that.
Liz, your last pick.
Oh yeah, I've got another one.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Now what balance have I got?
I've got a dramatic presentation
Some things that are related to publishers and people and to written words, so what am I not really covering?
Misinterpretations of Star Trek.
Alright, I'm gonna go for it.
I'm gonna pick video essay.
Oh hello.
I know no one's gonna snipe it, but I'm gonna go for it anyway.
And this is the best video essay on SF or related topics produced in the last year.
So this is non-fiction?
Yeah.
Primarily I think yeah.
Have been non you can add, you know, notable for its non-fictional content.
Um and this would cover again some of the things that have been in best related work.
Um, things like Lindsay Ellis's
video essays, Jenny Nicholson's video essays, H.
Bomber Guy, uh Folding Ideas, all these kinds of things.
I think there are a group of people who are putting out
good long form content that actually uses the video media as distinct from kinda long form podcasts.
They're basically a thing I like that does not have a Hugo, and so I'm going to invent one because I can.
I wouldn't have guessed, but I should have guessed that this would be your last pick, because I think
you are a big video essay gal.
How how much overlap is there here with Fancast?
Not much, because this is for standalone works.
So this is for standalone things, but also I think it includes a lot of people who are actually
professional video essayists now who are not eligible in fancast.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
But most fancast nominees are podcasts, not
Video channels.
Yeah, and we have seen some of the long videos go into best related.
No, I think this works.
I think this works
I think this might be part of why I often get a bit frustrated with Best Related is that I think it covers some stuff that I think should be covered elsewhere, but I want a space to put
Critical works.
So I'm putting them in other categories and then everyone will be happy with my definitive set of Hugos.
Yeah.
Okay.
My last one.
Alright, I'm gonna talk it through because this is my last category, so like I can't be sniped.
So I'm tempted by
B basically I'm thinking about art.
Ooh.
Um, and I think I might just do best art.
Yeah
Let's just go for it.
Best art.
I have made an art.
Okay, so I feel very sniped now.
The one art that is the best art.
Yeah.
Yeah
So is that best original artwork?
Yes.
That is the exact category that I was gonna do.
Oh I'm sorry.
Yeah, best original visual static art.
So Oh, so a sculpture that likes waves its arms doesn't
Count.
Oh god, that's I I more meant That's video.
That's video.
Yeah, that goes in Best Video Essay, Alison.
I don't know what you think.
Like Yeah.
No, but I I guess I don't wanna I wanna uh yes, okay.
Best Cold and Mobiles is what I'm thinking here.
I mean Best Art.
That's what I'm doing
And everyone knows what that means and I'm not bringing it to the business meeting so I don't have to define it properly.
So you've just nicked the whole of art, so I can't have any art even if I want it, because you've taken you've just
Artists you can't have art.
Yeah.
Loophole.
Yeah, I don't really want artists, do I?
'Cause it's bad.
Okay.
Or are you still thinking it through?
I'm gonna pick best fan artist and I'm gonna define it properly.
Ho ho ho hokay.
Oh, good luck with that
We've only been trying for twenty years.
I think I interact with fan art more than I interact with
pro art and the types of pro art I like the best are not typically the types of pro art that get nominated in pro art
By which I mean I quite like art for board games and I often nominate board game artists and they never ever ever get on the category because it's usually
people who are illustrating book covers, which is very like is a very worthy endeavor.
Whereas like I think one of the things I regret most about the move from
more traditional fanzines to online is that I think we lost a lot of the art culture when we did that and like we're kind of getting some of it back but it's it's slow going.
Um and like
you have loads of fanzines that never commission any art and I think that's really sad.
And so yeah, I think fan artist would be a good one to have.
Oh so you're having best fan artist?
I'm gonna go best fan artist, I've decided.
Which is great because I can have best original artwork as my my um last one.
It clearly includes flat art, it clearly includes sculpture, it clearly includes um
Good question.
What it doesn't include is those thirty-six minute films you get in art galleries by artists.
They all have to take their lumps in best dramatic presentation short form.
Or video essay.
Alright, so so video installations not art.
Video installations definitely are art, but they are covered by other categories in our awards.
But also the number of video installations I've sat and watched in galleries going, you know what, this is a film, and they should be competing for attention with other films.
Yeah, it is a ma yes, I think good video installations can be good.
Yes
But I will agree with Alison that I have seen many that are basically just YouTube videos that are in art galleries and I think that is not quite the same thing
Uh YouTube videos that are in art galleries, student film projects that are in art galleries.
Honestly I could do better on my iPhone that are in art galleries.
Um that's actually that last one is a lie to be honest.
But you know the sentiment
Um so yes, but obviously sculptures that wave their arms definitely count here, you know.
Um the vote for follicon rocket would have been fine.
Tubemen.
Hmm.
Wavy tubeman
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That was the that was the specific thing I was thinking of.
So Best Original Artwork is my last one.
I didn't think I was gonna become the vide the video defender here, but apparently so.
I've got a category for it.
Alan's like art, except these things I don't think are art.
No, I do think they're art, but I think they're a best dramatic presentation short form as well, please.
Oh well I don't have that, so it's it's tricky, right, Liz, because if someone writes a poem on the wall of of like an exhibition in an art gallery and you've got a best poem, Hugo, does that go in original artwork or poem?
Mm.
Which we don't, incidentally.
So I take your point.
I'm not saying that they don't then they are definitely valid art, but the problem is that art could theoretically encompass all human achievement, which is why it yeah, we gotta
That's why you went for f for artist instead.
Yeah.
Alright, fair enough, fair enough.
That's eighteen Hugos, that's plenty.
And and please write in with your objectively better sets of Hugo Awards.
Yes.
What did we pick that was bad?
What did we pick that was good?
Please comment away listeners.
W What's massively missing
And that was our Hugo Award draft.
As I said, we'll take these to the business meeting, we'll get them ratified, and in a couple of years' time, listeners, you can choose which Hugo Award to participate in
Get your Om and Crasson recommendations ready.
You can actually you can actually vote in all three of them there, can't you?
No.
Mine you've gotta pick.
If you're voting in either of the other two, you're in a y you are not welcome in mine.
Well, okay, good luck with that.
Yep.
Scorched Earth policy.
As the person who's awarding Best Novel, I'm happy for as many lesser lesser award sets to compete as would like.
Ho ho ho
Savage.
So basically John is the PGA tour and uh one of us is a petra funded alternative.
Probably me with my uh best universe.
Is that golf?
That is a golf joke, yeah.
That may be our first golf joke.
It might be, yeah.
It's probably the first and last golf joke you will ever get on Octothorpe.
Yeah, we'd have to have some balls to do another one.
That was the Octothorpe podcast, and it's goodbye for me.
It's goodbye for me, and it's goodbye for me.
And then a seventh terrible category.
Yeah, which I'm gonna I'm I I I can write it in the chat as a prediction.
Yeah.
Or I could just say it out loud.
I'm assuming you're gonna pick Armand Cresson.
Hm, I n I think I think Almond croissant is a little bit restrictive, so I am gonna go for best pastry.
Oh what?
This is an outrage.
I think the Hugos really need a best pastry category and I think when we get our Hugo package it should include a batch of pastry because that would'll be really good.
And then I could eat my pastries while I'm listening to the best fan casts and reading the best short stories and so on.
And watching the best movies
That's fair.
I am going to pick best dice.
Is that best dye?
No, it's best dice.
So it's more than one die.
It's I think it can either be a single die or it can be sets of dice.
But just dice rather than like bones or uh you know, knuckle bones or sticks or other counting objects.
Um, yeah, I think I think if the knuckle bones are dice, they count and if they're not, they don't.
Ah, so yeah no no no.
So okay.
I don't want like I don't when Robert Silverberg dies, I don't want someone to take his knuckle bones out and have them be eligible.
Do is it need does it need to be a a platonic solid?
No.
Does it do they need to I I mean, you know D tens are welcome here.
D10 oh yeah but okay so the thing about a D10 is that it's pretty good because all the faces are the same shape and it's obviously fair.
That's like uh it's that might be my limit.
I I'm speaking of somebody who bought twenty-five sets of polyhedral dice the other week for vibes.
How's that buy nothing life going, Alison?
Very badly.
That was actually the low point, but did do do you know I keep go going swimming?
Well that's good.
So it's balance.
I can't actually manage to keep my shit together in more than one aspect of my life at once.
Alright.
Liz, do you have a silly pick?
Best universe ayy Oh I literally pick this as one of my main picks.
Is this like best setting
This is like Star Trek vs.
Star Wars vs.
Lord of the Rings.
Fight it out.
You can only win it once.
Every year you can be nominated again as long as something in that universe was created in the last year.
interpreted in a very liberal way and it will get me a lot of debate on internet forums and that's the sort of word of mouth you want.
Oh
James Bond.
Yep.
But that's but James Bond's obviously been nominated in Best Vibes, so I'm afraid you can't have that one.
He's immortal, so that's science fictional.
Hang on, are you saying that Moonraker isn't genre because Moonrakers are James Bond definitely has some genre bits
Liz, is our real universe eligible for this Hugo Ward?
Yes, but it can only win once.
It's never gonna win.
The theme music for this episode was Surf Shimmy by Kevin McLeod at incompetech dot.
com used under a Creative Commons Attribution 4.
0 license.
This podcast will end at the beep.
Beep.